tomar un tren para huir de la guerra
Esto es lo que han decidido madres en el
don Bass salen de la ciudad de bookcraft
a 70 kilómetros al noroeste de daniesk
una zona donde los combates son
encarnizados y donde se concentra
actualmente la ofensiva rusa mientras el
tren Se dirige hacia el oeste Elvira y
sus dos hijos seguirán su viaje hacia
Eslovaquia
no muy lejos de nosotros una casa fue
atacada recientemente murieron personas
resultaron heridos y acabaron en
hospitales en estado grave Así que no
puedo poner a mis hijos en peligro mi
marido y yo hemos decidido marcharnos de
nuevo
en toda la región la gente vive bajo el
fuego de los misiles con miedo constante
los misiles vuelan constantemente son
ruidosos
Ana y sus hijos se dirigen a nipro a
casi 200 kilómetros en el don vast una
ciudad donde la situación es actualmente
más tranquila
decidimos que había que poner a salvo a
los niños y llevarlos a un lugar seguro
el ejército ruso está concentrando sus
esfuerzos en el don en los últimos días
sobre todo en los alrededores de la
ciudad de bakmut bajo intenso asedio el
grupo paramilitar Wagner que combate
junto a los rusos anunció la toma de un
pueblo a Sólo dos kilómetros del centro
de pacmut Perú Ucrania desmintió dicha
avanzada y la calificó de no exitosa en
respuesta los ucranianos volaron una
barricada en un intento por frenar el
avance ruso